[Music]
welcome back to careful boys everybody
we are currently off the record so
anything you say or do cannot be used
against you in the court of law
i like that in that case nick i hear uh
you got some food poisoning lately what
a little bit only [ __ ] get food
poisoning dude
yeah you look like [ __ ]
what
this just turned into a roast
and it just [ __ ] dies in me and i
didn't even get food poisoning like a
cool way you lost to a germ dude i did i
got kind of wrecked by this germ so what
happened what'd you eat i went to um i
haven't been to my my mother-in-law's
carne asada like in a while or we all
kind of gather as a family and then we
kind of just eat carne asada and like we
haven't done that oh she makes it she
makes it okay so we all went and then uh
one of the aunties brought some some
chorizo right ooh
and i had a piece because i was like oh
i'm excited i haven't had a choice in a
while so i ate some of that homemade
tortillas or i don't know i think it was
store-bought but i think what the issue
is is that maybe was slightly
undercooked and you had just taken the
[ __ ] and didn't wash your hands right no
that's not true no okay just want to
make sure he took a [ __ ] wiped it bear
because he forgot the toilet paper and
he went i don't really wipe i take [ __ ]
i just don't wipe oh you save the planet
but i saved the planet dude nick white
his ass without toilet paper just bare
hands i just shake it off nick done wait
man i cut it and i shake it off if you
can wipe and there's nothing there
that's good luck
it's sick yeah it's a good day and
that's why luna is up 8 000. that's true
no anyway so so i it was fine i was
totally fine and then the next morning i
woke up and i was just sitting up in bed
and i was like yo i don't feel good my
girl's sleeping
and then i i was like i kind of had the
urge to throw up but i was like nah nah
i'm not a [ __ ]
that's right you better not push it down
you suppress it and i'm sitting up and
i'm like fighting with myself digest
that [ __ ] yeah you digest it you fight
it like a man and then you look at
you're going like
yeah well [ __ ] that's kind of what
happened where oh where i'm in bed and
like
i'm starting to get up cause i'm like oh
no like i'm about to yeah oh no no no no
no no
yeah and it was like that worked and my
cheeks filled up is that your nose oh
[ __ ] and then a little bit came out of
no return right there so a little bit
came out but it was like it came so
quick it like it just filled up my cheek
so quick that i ran to the bathroom and
i just started like laying waste just
puking oh you made it i made it to the
toilet except the little that came out a
little bit came on i went prematurely
evaluated yeah honestly and i was just i
was just puking in the toilet i was like
doing it for like 15 minutes and my wife
was asleep and all she hears is like
just like the loudest vomit all your
masculinity leaving your body dude it
was awful but you know nobody likes
throwing up but then obviously i was
kind of laid out for a couple hours and
we're we're laying in bed did you have
another episode was just one hard one it
was one hard one and then i was like
kind of [ __ ] up so i was like nauseous
all day
and then it was like midday like four
o'clock my girl's like let's there's a
donut shop by our place that we like and
it's very good good idea and she goes
hey i want to go get a donut do you want
to come walk with me and i was like yeah
i could probably use some fresh air
right so i'm like i need probably to get
moving a little bit so i get up i start
getting dressed but while i'm getting
dressed i'm kind of feeling like i gotta
like take a seat i was like oh [ __ ] like
i'm getting nauseous but i was like
don't be a [ __ ] dude you're [ __ ]
don't be a little [ __ ] don't be a [ __ ]
walk your girl to the donut shop and
then come back like a man i'm like yeah
i'm good so we walk
we walk all the way and then i'm kind of
like oh [ __ ] i'm like getting hot i'm
getting like nauseous i'm like sweaty a
little bit but i'm like i'm totally fine
i'm fine
and
we're walking to the donut shop and i go
you know what i'm not going to go inside
i'm feeling a little something's going
on so i give my girl the cash she goes
inside
and then i'm standing outside i'm just
trying to hold it together did you feel
it coming up not really not really i
just felt like really easy
no i just feel nauseous
and then there's a laundromat that comes
out that's like right next door and
there's a lady comes out there's white
lady and she she's walking by and then
there's another guy that comes out
saying man man ma'am you you left
something in the laundromat and as soon
as i heard that i looked and then all of
a sudden i just started yakking
this little trash can dude it was there
there was no there was no there was no
grass anywhere like it was it was as
immediate as it was in the morning
it was i swear to god like i i hear them
go ma'am you left something and i'm like
and my dumb ass is like oh would you
leave and i look over and i go oh no and
i start
walking and it's dude i felt like i felt
terrible i felt awful because i was like
dude this is the side this is the worst
i'm outside this [ __ ] places business
it looks like you're reacting to
chivalry yeah and i was like this is
making me sick to my stomach and i'm
just throwing a like gatorade at this
point right why didn't you do the covert
protocol like this yeah elbow hold your
breath
is that what i swear
i make a little well yeah
but i just was like dude it's going
everywhere
you gotta make a [ __ ] yellow stone
dude yeah dude and i'm like well we've
gotta go you gotta go so i'm like puking
like i puked like four or five times
and then my girl comes out
it was all gatorade fruit punch and then
my girl comes out and she's like with
donuts in her hand she's like oh my god
are you okay and i'm like tears running
up my face like
just just
families bring that third world country
[ __ ] into my house exactly exactly so
i'm just yakking and none of them got
sick and that's why that's why they
think you're a little [ __ ] because
they're like [ __ ] only one and then my
girl asks our uncle and she goes because
he was one of the only ones that ate the
chorizo too and he's like no i'm fine
and i'm like [ __ ] i feel like it's a
whole [ __ ] probably just got the
undercooked pieces man oh yeah and i had
i was the first one to eat it so there
you go she should have waited
as soon as i'm throwing up and then my
girl comes out and i'm like all right
let's walk back home
i see this lady in this uh like jag this
jaguar and she's this asian chicken i
feel so bad for her
she's she's facing me right and she's
literally trying to look away
because she's like mortified because i'm
you know like when you sometimes for
some people when they see someone
throwing oh yeah i don't like that like
projectile vomit they can't i didn't see
[ __ ] chunks on the ground yeah i
think that it was a just gate right it
just looked like blood
i was vomiting blood and and this poor
lady is like i felt so bad right in
front of you she's looking away just
trying her best to not throw up she's
like i was gonna get donuts
and it looks like she was waiting for
food because there's like a really great
she's inside her jaguar
and i'm like hey we gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here did you try to piss your
vomit off at least piss it off like whip
my penis
oh piss it off just get mad at it yeah
do a little power washing honestly i
probably should have had like maybe
bought a water or something like but it
was just like
there was nothing i could have done and
it was mostly just moisture you're like
a dog walker that doesn't hold [ __ ] bags
yeah and i kind of feel like a piece of
[ __ ] because that's like one of my
biggest gripes is like people that leave
their [ __ ] everywhere or their blood
vomits yeah dude and i was like i'm
really embarrassed and well that's why
you pay your taxes that's why
who says i do that you made a job and
you created a job you're a job creator
i was walking with you so embarrassing
and there's an alleyway there and i was
like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] someone threw
up and i could tell they had carrots and
stuff
and then i walked a little bit down and
i'm like maybe like three to four feet
away i'm like
oh damn this will [ __ ] throw up and
[ __ ] [ __ ] all over the place and then
i walk with that you can see like the
dry piss mark and you could just tell
like the person's whole night like this
whole night
i'm like dad's gonna have a rough
[ __ ]
few steps later you see him on the floor
with an empty 40 ounce
like oh bro nah dude if he got the [ __ ]
and throw up he's actually probably on
the street corner like hey how you doing
he got it all that feels amazing yo when
i yacked i felt way better yeah and i
was like kind of on the other side of
like that the the third time or that was
just that was it that was it just the
big finale does this happen to you a lot
no
not to the point where i like just
through like you know i don't get food
poisoning that's the last time that you
threw up like that or just at all when's
the last time you barf previous time i
don't years ago i remember one time i
threw up at a gas station when i was in
uh
coming back from san francisco and it
was i had food poisoning from like crab
cakes i think and i slept the whole car
ride because i was like i don't feel
good and then like the halfway point i
get out the car and i'm like man i'm
totally fine and i felt like like kind
of nauseous but i was the whole time i
was like fighting it and then i just
yacked and i was like oh my god i just
threw up and i just go in the bathroom
and
just did my business and i went back to
sleep and i got home three hours after
that midpoint and i just started
unloading everywhere and that was like
the last time i got crazy food poisoning
dude i was hanging out with the buddy
and he and i didn't even feel like
throwing up at all and then all of a
sudden he takes out his phone and he
shows me his cardana portfolio
i thought oh i just start projecting all
[ __ ] thrown up all over the place
[Laughter]
and he still thinks it's going to pump
yeah he's still thinking he still thinks
cardano's going to pump yeah i have such
a phobia for throwing up i haven't
thrown up in 21 years
that's a man right there you're just
surprised
what are your techniques like i [ __ ]
threw up two weeks ago ice cold uh pack
on my head
and then and then just like sleep and
then i'll look i wake up and i'll have
the [ __ ] worst diarrhea on recorded
man's history but i don't throw up
throwing up is rough you have a chili
diary because of that a what a chili
diarrhea like
no like it's cold
uh cold one
spicy no
cold every time i have a cold diary i'm
like oh okay
i was definitely using an ice pack last
night
today's video is brought to you by tushy
now big thanks to tushy for keeping my
tushy clean because i've been using it
for several years now and not only does
my booty hole feel immaculate after a
nice little cocka you know what ends up
happening i actually saved a lot of
money on toilet paper and that was a
surprise that i was like wow i didn't
realize how much toilet paper i was
using yeah because before if you have
poops like me you gotta wipe i don't
know maybe like 12 times or something
but with two she
you just gotta dab like a gentleman
right here because it's it really does
all the showering for you it just ass
blasts you
and then you're just like now i just
gotta like dry up and dab the moisture
yeah it cleans it up it's easy you don't
even need an electrician you don't need
a plumber like some of the other ones so
it's super easy to use you save on
tissue paper and you feel fresh like you
could you know sometimes the things that
i hate is like you take a shower and
then you gotta poop right after you're
done
this feels like you just took a shower
on your butt yep and it really cuts down
your tp usage by 80
and i was wondering why i'm not buying
toilet paper and i'm just like
especially during the pandemic when
everyone was hoarding [ __ ] toilet
paper i'm like ha joke's on you because
i don't even have to go to the store so
we want all of our listeners which is
you guys to have clean butts like us too
so go to hellotushy.com off the record
to get 10 percent off plus free shipping
that's hellotushy.com
off the record to get 10
off and free shipping
i feel like when i hold in my throw up
though and then i finally do it actually
makes like i feel like that shit's been
brewing for some time all the [ __ ]
bacteria has been spreading so i feel
like it makes me sicker yeah
i mean you're supposed to throw up what
you have to throw up but i just can't
bear to do it
why i'll do whatever
thing i hate the feeling of throwing up
but after after you do you feel
immediately better why did you throw up
two weeks ago i just drank too much
[Laughter]
i've done that a long time but you know
sometimes life just asks you me and
steve will you'll be taking shots but
sometimes you take shots sometimes you
need to you know oh you know that's the
last time i threw up actually was a
friend's giving
at my buddy's place and everybody was
like let's take a shot i don't drink
right and it was like one shot of uh
patron i think
and i've taken that before and i felt
fine but for whatever reason this one
just obliterated me
like it completely obliterated me and we
were like eating dinner and then i was
like oh my god i have to throw up and
i'm like one shot
it was i remember the moment like i felt
immediately drunk
i was talking to a friend and then all
of a sudden i feel everything start like
shaking and kind of coming together and
like just feeling really like oh my god
like that's on some other [ __ ] though
then yeah it probably wasn't just
because there are times where like um
i can [ __ ] drink like a tank and i'm
like barely buzzed there's just time
well i don't know if it's something i
ate that day or just or didn't eat that
day didn't eat right and i'm just like
i'm just a gangster but then there are
other days when i feel like my throat's
closing i take like half a shot i'm like
oh man it's gonna be difficult today
maybe you shouldn't drink any more
alcohol i can't drink at all at all
purple there you go why you gotta say it
like that you [ __ ] perky little guy
look at the judgment look at this
okay
maybe you shouldn't drink the thing that
makes you throw up it's just all i'm
saying
quite logical it's a poison no but i
mean if i drink every day and i throw up
like once every three years i feel like
the ratios are good pretty good that's
pretty good i took joe to the sushi
restaurant i found it was really good
and then i don't know what happened but
that day like the uh
it's really good but they they forgot
like half the order
and then so we kept asking like we have
the order and when they finally brought
it in it was good
and then when i went home um i started
like
feeling nauseous like i could almost
feel like in slow motion like if my
stomach was a balloon like it was
getting it was bloating
it was feeling like that and i'm like oh
no this is going to be so [ __ ] bad
and i don't want i hate throwing up too
so i just chug like a bunch of
pepto-bismol and i'm gonna keep it down
my [ __ ] keep it down so i went in bed
and i laid there and i started having
like [ __ ] a fever and like chills and
stuff because i think it wants to come
out you know yeah but then i slept it
off and then the next day it felt better
but [ __ ] when i uh but then when i burp
like it still has the taste of yeah
because yeah it sucks i [ __ ] love
sushi so like like the last two weeks i
haven't ate sushi at all because it just
kind of i don't know how that should hit
you harder too because i woke up at
three in the morning just to take a [ __ ]
and it cleared digestion we ate the same
[ __ ] and i was like damn dude i thought
i was being a little [ __ ] but sushi
yeah you got japanese blood in you so
you can true it's a little bit more like
more cultured into my culture have you
ever been at a friend's house where
you're like all right i definitely don't
want to take a [ __ ] here yeah so you're
like but but i definitely experienced a
food situation like a food planting
situation so i was like i gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here i live like eight
minutes away but it's la so traffic
sucks so i was like okay i can make it i
can make it so i get him i get in my
mini i start driving and i just [ __ ]
[ __ ] my pants
shut the [ __ ] up
like with it dude within like 45 seconds
as soon as you sat in and you closed the
door oh [ __ ] it's coming out you could
feel it you can control you
at least my body hooked me up enough
where like the door closes i [ __ ] my
pants
[Laughter]
it was all over you had to drive in
traffic hot la for a whole hour with
[ __ ] in your pants unfortunately it was
night time did you soil the seat or did
it stay contained in your wranglers i
didn't even i thought i i definitely
because you you can't tell right in that
situation you don't know how much is
bleeding through true yeah you just know
it's the fog of war
but when i stood up expecting to see
like uh you know a wet mark or something
nothing i was like wow
diesel jeans bro you get diesel jeans
and you can [ __ ] in those things and you
also got some good ideas too they're
designed for the for the average [ __ ]
yeah that's they got to market that more
honestly yeah there are times where like
you you feel that feeling
and then you're like i can make like i
don't want to [ __ ] [ __ ] myself and
you're like
i could [ __ ] make this i could make
this and i'm going to hold it as hard as
i can
and then but but then also in my mind
i've already surrendered i'm like if i
have to pull over on the [ __ ] freeway
i'm just gonna [ __ ] on this [ __ ]
even though i surrendered i'm already
like it's gonna if it happens
i'm not better than nobody yeah
i like to surrender who the [ __ ] am i
but i already surrendered but thank god
i never have you guys ever been in a
situation where that's ha like you had
to like poop like that i almost [ __ ] on
bart's bush
the other day goes oh my god i got a
[ __ ] yeah that's true
bart was taking his sweet ass time hey
guys and he's open hurry up and open
that [ __ ] door i'm gonna take a [ __ ]
on myself
i was actually uh going through and then
hannah was like he does
i was going to an airport with mike's
song one time and also food poisoning um
this is also on the same trip it might
be a frame food poisoning while
traveling is the worst
on a plane so i couldn't even teach my
class so he taught it uh i i sat down
and i was just like telling stuff and
then he was like my body
um and then we had to go we had to
travel to go home and this [ __ ] uh
long ass terminals
right really really long terms you're
sweating balls the whole time
this was coming back from france i think
the super super long terminals and then
for whatever reason
for the international report that we're
coming out of um the men's bathroom was
closed of course right men's bathroom
because women's bathroom was open
and then bathroom was closed [ __ ]
friends so i had to go to the [ __ ]
thing and look at the directory to see
where all the other men's restroom is
men's restroom on the other side of the
terminal i go all the way over there
with my rolly and i'm sweating you know
when you're like traveling it's very
who cares and when you're when you have
to poop you're sweating too yeah so it's
really really difficult well all the way
to the other one
also closed oh so they closed both men's
bathrooms they closed both why'd you
gamble like that you wanted to [ __ ]
anthony lee over there so then i went
halfway back and i was just like there's
a family restroom
uh for kids oh the one with the koala on
it that's fair game though that's very
pleasant but the toilet's hella small
but it's a locked one where you could
just take the pipes or regulations so
rather than going into a women's
restroom obviously the men's ones
weren't available i've [ __ ] out of many
women yeah why are you so classy what
the [ __ ] up with that i i decimate a
[ __ ] chick's bathroom if i had to go
i think the kids restroom i just felt
like it was a little bit more it had the
the male figure still drawn on the wall
so i thought it was okay but either way
it's funny though because you have to
take a huge [ __ ] and then one in the
women's yeah just take your porn down
exactly when you have to take no when
you have to take a huge [ __ ] and then
it's a small toilet your [ __ ] looks way
bigger oh yeah like like it's coming out
the water that's available on the thing
so man it was the craziest feeling just
trying to like fit my [ __ ] on this
little thing
my like knees are in my chin because
like it's like down to the floor but
that probably feels like
the oh yeah squatty yeah
yeah that feels good but i [ __ ]
filled it have you ever [ __ ] on her
shoes what i was i was in taiwan doing
this [ __ ] like little like tour trip
thing and that's like bark questions
and then we went to uh we went to a
night market and we had the most
delicious bowl of beef noodle soup but i
don't know what happened didn't feel
good and i remember they're like taking
us into this one like small little town
that's on the side of a mountain and
like oh this place is
for their pineapple cakes i'm like i
don't give a [ __ ] i need to [ __ ] [ __ ]
my brain
and i was going and i was going to and a
lot of those shops they're like they're
like they they live there you know like
the bottom is their shop and then and
then their house is upstairs so you
can't really use their bathroom because
you're going into their house home yeah
yeah and i finally found one that was
one of those bathrooms that's kind of
like here's a restaurant and you walk
outside it's like an outhouse there's no
house
it's a hole in the ground yeah okay and
then even the tiles are uneven because
it's just kind of like rural janky yeah
and but i just had the craziest [ __ ]
diarrhea so i try to get him like the
widest horse
but man that [ __ ] just [ __ ] came out
and i was like splashing the insides of
my shoes
[Applause]
not a [ __ ] and then they didn't have
[ __ ] toilet paper i don't know why
and then so i came out with some customs
on
and i took my underwear i wiped my ass
and then i wet i wiped my shoes
it just smeared all of it and i tried
and when i got back on the tour bus
should have had a tushy i know i had a
backpack i was trying not to like i was
trying to like sit on the tour bus like
this so i don't have to like touch it
with anything oh god and that's the end
of our [ __ ] show
[Music]
you